Combining science-fiction action with crude
humor, a vast mythology, and just the tiniest
bit of heart, Rick & Morty was an instant
hit when it debuted on Adult Swim in late
2013.
The creation of animator and voice actor Justin
Roiland and Community creator Dan Harmon,
the animated series follows the adventures
of a somewhat reprehensible, usually drunk
scientist, and his kind of dumb grandson,
as they travel through space, time, and alternate
dimensions messing up history, the universe,
and their own lives in the process.
Here's a look at the untold truth of Rick
& Morty.
Doc and Mharti
The whole thing started when Roiland made
an animated short called "The Real Animated
Adventures of Doc and Mharti" : a very thinly
veiled, sexually-explicit parody of Back to
the Future.
If that sounds insane, that's because it is.
"Great scott!"
Roiland's cartoons were screened as part of
a weekly film showcase in Los Angeles run
by Harmon.
When Harmon got temporarily fired from Community,
he approached Roiland about adapting "Doc
and Mharti" into a recurring series that toned
down some of the more explicit sexual content.
Doc became Rick, Mharti became Morty, and
Bird Person became whatever he is.
"It has been a challenging mating season for
Bird Person."
"Then it's time to get your beak wet tonight,
playa!
Have some fun out there, Bird Person."
Gas giant
"I have a new (BURP) catchphrase.
I need your help, Morty.
I mean we gotta get the hell out of here and
go take care of business.
(BURP) (BURP) It's important.
Come on Morty!"
Rick's endless burping is definitely gross
— and it’s definitely real.
Roiland, who voices both Rick and Morty, says
that during voiceover recording, he'll read
through Rick's lines once, and mark down where
he wants to insert the burps later.
With the help of a bunch of Miller 64 and
water, Roiland goes back and re-records his
dialogue, this time with the belches in their
proper place.
He says the "whole process is disgusting."
"You can’t just add a sci-fi word to a car
word and hope it means something."
That’s not the only all-natural part of
the process.
The off-the-cuff feel to much of the dialogue
is because Roiland engages in a process of
improvisation during recording.
After running Rick's lines, Roiland does a
readthrough for Morty, and then does a take
of the scene as both characters, letting himself
riff.
The end result is a collage of scripted and
improvised lines that are animated around,
resulting in some pretty amazingly weird,
and occasionally drunk, stuff.
Instagram innovation
Hundreds of shows have debuted on the internet,
but Rick & Morty is the first to ever premiere
an entire episode on Instagram.
Due to Instagram's video limitation of 15
seconds, that meant the 2014 episode, “Rixty
Minutes,” had to be cut up into 109 separate
videos.
Building on its unique success, the show team
also did something else nobody had done on
Instagram before: use it as a game platform.
Rickstaverse launched in the summer of 2015.
Players must follow tags and other clues to
bounce through more than 80 Instagram accounts
set up and dedicated exclusively to the game.
More than 129,000 people took part in Rickstaverse,
which involved 11 explorable planets and more
than 1,000 individual images, and tied into
the Season Two cliffhanger.
It even offered players the opportunity to
contribute to Season Three by naming a weird
alien blob.
The Couch Gag
"Oh my god, did you do?
You killed The Simpsons, Morty!"
"I didn't mean to!"
"Oh god look at the baby one!
Oh my god Morty!"
In 2016, the Rick & Morty team put together
one of the most memorable Simpsons "couch
gags" in recent memory.
Justin Roiland had heard that Simpsons creator
Matt Groening was a fan of his show, so he
asked Groening to provide the commentary track
on the DVD release of the first season of
Rick & Morty.
Groening agreed, and brought along longtime
Simpsons writer and producer Al Jean, who
asked Roiland to do the time-traveling couch
bit, and surprisingly, allowing him to brutally
murder Springfield’s first family.
Not only that, but the couch gag also doubled
as a Futurama crossover.
And given the fact that Rick and Morty takes
place in a vast multi-verse, it’s not surprising
that this isn’t the show’s only crossover.
Gravity Falls
Though they come from very different places
and have very different audiences, the connections
between Gravity Falls and Rick and Morty are
too plentiful to ignore.
Gravity Falls creator Alex Hirsch has done
voice work on Rick and Morty, and Roiland
has returned the favor on Hirsch's show.
"That’s amazing.
Are you from the future or something?"
"Uh no!
Who told you that!
Memory wipe!"
"This is a baby wipe."
Not too surprising, since they used to share
an office at the Disney Channel.
But it goes deeper.
For example, Gravity Falls' evil, pyramid-shaped
dream demon Bill Cipher briefly appeared in
Rick & Morty.
As Hirsch told Entertainment Weekly, it’s
a dream come true, saying.
“For some reason, the universe has blessed
us with our mad wishes, and it occurred to
us — let's start doing things nobody else
does, that maybe you're not supposed to do.
We started putting little Easter eggs in our
shows that sort of connected the two.
Our motivation for that is primarily to freak
people out and blow their minds."
One of the most mind-blowing Easter eggs occurs
when, spoiler alert, items sucked into a portal
in Gravity Falls pop out through a portal
in Rick and Morty.
Rick's a mystery
As vast and complicated as the Rick & Morty
mythos has become, Roiland and Harmon never
want to give too much information about the
history of Rick.
Harmon told The AV Club,
"...we're very careful about delving into
Rick's backstory, because when we do, we don't
want there to be any shocking surprises."
Like Yoda and Tommy Wiseau, Rick’s real
story may never be revealed, and that’s
just one of the show’s many mysteries.
The plot thickens
The show's creative staff decided they wanted
to have a "secret" about the show's world
that only they would know.
They would never explicitly reveal their secret
during the run of Rick & Morty, but they did
want to place clues throughout.
Because fans are weirdly obsessive, someone
managed to figure out the secret and posted
it on Reddit.
Roiland confirmed that someone figured it
out, but didn't identify the secret.
Based on the posts related to these theories
and Roiland's reaction, fans have narrowed
it down the most likely possibilities.
Could Rick be an older version of Morty?
Or is he one of the many versions of Morty?
Is Rick is aware that he’s a fictional character?
"See you next week, everybody!"
Or maybe Rick's flask isn't filled with booze,
but instead the powerful "mega seeds."
"You gotta put these seeds inside your butt."
"In my butt?"
"Come on Morty—please Morty!
You have to do it Morty!"
"Oh man…"
You know, the ones that temporarily make you
smart, but then kinda cripple you for a while?
"Oh geez."
"I'm sorry Morty, it's a bummer.
In reality you're as dumb as they come."
But the most important question of all: will
there ever be another season of Community?
"Never."
"Never!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!